si j'ai arrêté les réseaux sociaux il
faut que je donne juste une précision
j'ai été très actif sur les réseaux
sociaux pendant 12 ans et puis j'adorais
ça et puis je trouvais ça formidable
je trouve ça formidable d'abord parce
que pour moi c'était la possibilité peut
être d'une autre parole et c'était
peut-être quelque chose qui sortait du
jeu habituel des chroniqueurs des
machins des sachants des types au dessus
avec leurs spécialités qui viennent dire
ce que c'est que la réalité vous ce que
c'est que la vie est le problème c'est
qu'en fait on a plus ou moins
intériorisé en fait cette fonction et
c'est qu'à partir d'un moment d'un
certain moment mais j'apprends vite
c'est peut-être aussi que c'était là dès
le début je ne voyais pas j'en sais rien
mais enfin quoi je les repérer vraiment
à partir de cette année finalement
j'avais l'impression qu'on était tous en
train de se transformer en chroniqueur
tous tout au log tous spécialistes de
l'hydro chlorite chloroquine tout cela à
tous ceux et fidelio log
c'était terrible c'était terrible et en
fait la qualité des réseaux sociaux qui
était au départ en tout cas pour moi
c'était comme ça que je le voyais la
possibilité que les timides se met à
parler les timides
d'un coup c'était quand même les grandes
gueules qui reprenait le dessus et ce
qui est donc du coup c'était pour avoir
on va dire un rapport plus un avec moi
même et avec les autres que j'utilisais
de fermer ce truc là j'ai pris le petit
blog pour dire aux gens qui m'aiment
bien ça existe et que je suis pas mort
et que tout va bien que ça continue et
sinon on communique autrement et on
communique beaucoup mieux par mail par
téléphone de façon directe parce que si
vous voulez ce truc de transformer enfin
la fenêtre qui a été supposé de la
fenêtre du dehors qui étaient les
réseaux sociaux quand justement ça se
ferment tout autour alors elle devient
elle aussi une espèce de mur qui nous
empêche de voir derrière et on se
retrouve pris dans le temps brûlants de
l'actualité et qui est une sorte
d'impossibilité d'avancé en fait donc
c'est pour essayer de commencer à faire
des trous dans le mur
pour voir derrière
[Musique]